all right next segment people let's talk
a little bit
about vaccines and everything going on
with covet and as i've been saying to
you i'm sort of feeling lately that
because it's very obvious that covet is
never going away it's going to be this
constant crudgel that they can always
use to control us and and lock us down
and put more rules on us and all of the
stuff that you all get right since
they're always going to do that i feel
like if i talk about it a little bit
less maybe it'll give it a little less
oxygen and if you guys just go about
your life
as you see fit maybe that's the only way
we we get past this thing it's not going
to be a top-down thing where they
suddenly start saying to us oh you can
you can have your life back
but there were two interesting videos
that i saw this morning from nba players
talking about vaccines and we know by
the way that there are many many i don't
know if we have specific numbers on it
yet are there are there specific numbers
on nfl and nba and mlb players taking
vaxes um but we know that there are a
ton of professional athletes who don't
want to take the vaccines right these
are people usually in their early 20s
mid-20s who are at the peak of physical
performance right who eat right who
exercise who take care of themselves who
we all wish uh we could basically uh
emulate and look like and live that kind
of life um and a lot of them are saying
we don't want to get vaccinated actually
michael's showing me some numbers right
now in the nfl it appears that 93
are vaccinated i mean we'll see what
happens to those other seven percent but
there were two videos yesterday that are
going viral right now this first one is
orlando magic player jonathan isaac
talking about vaccines talking about
immunity and everything else and just
listen to this video it's about a minute
long and you tell me who makes more
sense this guy or fauci uh what is it
about the vaccine that that makes you
uh
hesitant to to to get it uh i i would
start with um i've had covet um in the
past and so our understanding of
antibodies
of natural immunity has uh changed a
great deal from the onset of the
pandemic and it's still evolving
um
i understand that the vaccine would um
help if you catch covet and uh you'll be
able to have less symptoms um from
contracting it but with me having covert
in the past and having antibodies with
my current age group and a fitness
physical fitness level
it's not necessarily a fear of mine
taking the vaccine um
like i said it would decrease my chances
of
having a severe reaction but it does
open me up to the albeit rare chance but
the possibility of having an adverse
reaction to the vaccine itself
um i don't believe that being
unvaccinated means infected or being
vaccinated means
uninfected you can still catch covet
with or we're not having the vaccine
i would say honestly the the craziness
of it all in terms of not being able to
say that it should be everybody's fair
choice without being demeaned or um
talked crazy to doesn't uh make one
comfortable to do what said person is uh
telling them to do
um
yeah i would say that's that's a couple
of the reasons that um you know i would
say i'm hesitant at this time but at the
end of the day uh i don't feel that it
is um you know anyone's reason to come
out and say well this is why or this is
not why it should just be their decision
and um
you know loving your neighbors not just
loving those that that agree with you or
look like you are uh moving the same way
that you do it's it's a you know loving
those who don't
gosh isn't that refreshing
not only the information of what he's
saying that he had coveted he talks
about natural immunity talks about the
fact that just because you haven't been
vaccinated doesn't mean you
automatically
have covid um all of that stuff but just
the tenor and tone with which he speaks
right that is a good decent man we are
so uh bereft we're so void at this point
of good decent people on television or
in in the thought leader space that when
you hear someone just a decent guy this
is an nba player we just checked his
stats he's averaged about 10 points a
game he's been in the league for a
couple seasons i actually never heard of
him i don't watch the nba anymore as you
know because of the politics that
they've injected into the league so i
don't even know who he was uh but like
that's a good man like that's somebody i
would like to have dinner with and chat
with
and he talks about mutual respect and
everything else at the end and it's like
which message is that not a message that
we should be hearing more of right which
message are we always getting you better
do what we say or you're evil or you're
racist or you're an anti-vaxxer or a
conspiracy theory here is a decent man
telling you the truth telling you the
absolute truth uh we've got another
video actually from another nba player
this is washington wizards player and i
did know of him because he's been
playing for a couple years now bradley
beal
every player every person in this world
is gonna make their own decision for
themselves um
i would like an explanation to you know
people with vaccines why are they still
getting covered
if that's something that we are supposed
to highly be protected from like it's
funny that oh it reduces your chances of
going to the hospital
it doesn't eliminate anybody from
getting covered
right so everybody is everybody in here
i would assume right
so you all can still get covered right
we're less likely to die or go to the
hospital
okay but
you can still get coveted
right
so and you can still pass it along with
the facts right
i'm not as i'm just asking the question
oh sure
around
[Music]
but having it
change your opinion one way or another
like did it kind of re-emphasize i don't
need the backstage
no no no
no no no
no that didn't that wasn't the case i
mean
yeah i had it but that doesn't mean i
can't get it again you know
i mean it's no different than somebody
with a vaccine like i can yes i
developed antibodies for it so my
chances will be less likely now as well
right but
it's still a possibility i may get it
just like there are players and coaches
and
staff who are vacs and
missing camp right now because of itself
bradley beal of the washington wizards
who you saw right there is asking better
questions than anyone in the press corps
is asking of this administration
even when he says the line there he goes
i'm just asking a question
didn't that feel kind of interesting to
you because we're kind of being told at
this point that we can't ask questions
we better
just obey but his questions
are completely valid much like his
commentary is completely valid in
america i think
for a limited time remaining we're still
allowed to ask questions you're still
allowed to question authority you're
still allowed to push back you're still
out to say i am an autonomous individual
and i can make decisions for myself i
wonder
uh how much longer these two guys will
be in the nba because the nba is not too
kind to people who push back right the
nba has made it very clear that they are
a political organization backing black
lives matter that you're not allowed to
talk anti-china and i wonder if it's
going to be a little harder for those
guys to get contracts right now which is
why so many people are silent we did get
a little more info on the vaccinated
percentages of uh professional athletes
i said before the nfl 93 vaccinated mba
it appears 90 percent vaccinated but
also keep this in mind not only are
these guys at the the height of physical
fitness and all of that and eat right
and all the things that you're supposed
to do that we don't talk about anymore
right we don't talk about diet we don't
talk about exercise we just tell you to
stay home and order in chinese food all
of that not only is that all true but
the absolute farce
that sports has become where coaches
wear masks when they're on the sideline
and guess what happens then they call a
timeout and everyone huddles around and
the coach is screaming with the mask so
he always takes the mask down we've all
seen these videos or players they play
in the game they're sweating on each
other spitting on each other bleeding on
each other hacking each other scratching
each other and everything else that's
fine on the court then they get on the
bench they put the mask on it's all
nonsensical theater